Hello, everyone. My name is
Dr. Kornick. I am a family
medicine physician in
the OMM department on the
Arkansas campus, and I will
be giving you guys the lab
prep lecture for diagnosis
of the elbow and wrist.
Here are the objectives for
our lab and lecture. We're
going to review relevant
dermatomes, myotomes, and
peripheral nerve distributions.
We're going to review
some relevant anatomy of
the elbow, forearm, and
wrist. Then we're going to
move into diagnosing somatic
dysfunction in the elbow,
radial head, and wrist.
Let's start by reviewing
how we test the dermatomes
and myotomes associated
with our cervical nerve
roots. So for the
dermatomes of the C5 nerve
root, we're going to test
sensation at the lateral
antecubital fossa, just
proximal to the elbow.
C6 nerve root is
going to be testing
sensation at the
dorsal proximal thumb.
C7 nerve root is going
to be testing sensation
at the dorsal proximal
middle finger.
C8 is going to be
the dorsal proximal
little finger. And
then lastly, T1, we're
going to test
sensation at the medial
anticubital fossa, just
proximal to the elbow.
In terms of testing the
myotomes, C5 is going to
be tested with elbow flexion
and the biceps reflex.
C6 is going to be tested
with wrist extension
and the biceps reflex
and the supinator reflex.
C7 is going to be
tested by elbow
extension and the
triceps reflex.
C8 is going to be
tested by middle
finger flexion, and
T1 is going to be
tested with little
finger abduction.
For those that are
more visually inclined,
here are a couple
of images going
over the dermatomes
and myotomes again.
Now that we've reviewed
the dermatomes, I also want
to review the peripheral
nerve distributions and
where sensation is covered
by the peripheral nerves.
As you can imagine, if
we have a patient that is
presenting with symptoms of
numbness, tingling, or any
type of pain, we need
to consider not only the
dermatomes of the cervical
nerve roots that we just
reviewed, but also where
there may be peripheral nerve
injuries that may also be
causing their symptoms.
Let's break down the anatomy
of the elbow joint. So
the elbow joint is three
synovial joints, the ulno
-humeral joint, the radio
-humeral joint, and the
radial ulnar joint. Later
in this lecture, we'll talk
about how we diagnose
somatic dysfunction at the
ulno-humeral and radial
ulnar joints. But just to
review quick the primary
and secondary motions, so
ulno-humeral joint being
a hinge joint, the primary
motions are flexion and
extension. However, there
are secondary motions of
abduction and adduction.
The radial ulnar joint primary
motions are pronation
and supination.
The stability of the
elbow joint is primarily
from two collateral
ligaments that are very
strong triangular
thickenings around the
medial and lateral aspect
of the elbow joint.
These help to limit the
varus and valgus stress
on the joint and helps to
maintain that articular
contact. So on the lateral
aspect, it's going to
be the radial collateral
ligament, and this travels
from the lateral
epicondyle to the annular
ligament of the radial
head and radial notch. The
ulnar collateral ligament
is on the medial aspect,
and that goes from the
medial epicondyle to the
coronoid and olecronaut
processes, and you can see
those depicted in the
images on the right here.
Now let's get into the
details of the ulno-humeral
joint. You'll notice that I
have ulno in red and humeral
in blue, and that is because
the anatomical landmarks
that I have listed on this
slide I wanted you guys
to be able to associate
with the appropriate bone.
So for the first bullet
there, elbow flexion is
anatomically limited by the
coronoid fossa of the humerus
and the coronoid process
of the ulna. And so when we
look at the image on the
bottom right there, we can
see on the coronoid fossa
here of the humerus just
above the trochlea, and then
the coronoid process of the
ulna and how that wedges
in to that coronoid fossa
during elbow flexion. And
that is what our anatomical
limitation will be. For
elbow extension, that is
anatomically limited by the
olecranon fossa of the humerus
and the olecranon process
of the ulna. And so we
can see that in both the
medial view here and the
posterior view here, where
on the medial view, you can
see that C shape of the
olecranon and the trochlear
notch. And on the posterior
aspect, how that olecranon
process then in full
extension comes up and wedges
into that olecranon fossa
to have that bony end point.
Now the looseness between
the trochlea and the
trochlea notch, which I'll
get more into on the next
slide, but that's where
we're talking about this
aspect of the elbow
joint here, that is what
allows the medial ulnar
glide with distal forearm
abduction and supination,
and the lateral ulnar
glide with distal forearm
adduction and pronation.
again i have that same
color scheming going on with
the ulno humeral joint and
so let's talk more about
the trochlea and the trochlear
notch so the spiraled
fit of the trochlea and
trochlear notch and i have a
zoomed in picture looking
at the inferior aspect of
the trochlea of the humerus
and you can see that
oblique orientation and that
spiraled orientation of that
trochlea which is what is
responsible for the carrying
angle when the elbow is
extended and supinated.
In the middle here, we
have what a normal carrying
angle is considered for
both males and females.
And then on the
left here, we have a
decreased carrying angle
or a cubitus varus.
And on the right,
we have a cubitus
valgus or an increased
carrying angle.
Now let's talk about
the four somatic
dysfunctions of the
ulno-humeral joint.
Flexion and extension
somatic dysfunctions
are due to tightness
and hypertonicity
of the biceps and
triceps muscles.
Now before I go into abduction
and adduction somatic
dysfunctions, I just want
to make a disclaimer.
Please utilize the terminology
of how we are naming
an abduction and adduction
somatic dysfunction of
the ulno-humeral joint
in the lecture and in the
lab handout, as there are
other outside resources that
can use the terms abduction
and adduction which
describes a slightly
different motion at the elbow
joint and so to avoid
confusion and be consistent
please utilize the way that
we are naming the omohumeral
joint somatic dysfunctions
as this is how you
will be graded on your
written and practical exams
so when we're talking about
abduction and adduction
somatic dysfunctions we're
talking about a preference
of either medial or lateral
glide of the proximal
ulna. Now, these are
accessory rocking motions of
the proximal ulna on the
trochlea of the humerus.
We can also induce these
motions by supinating and
pronating the forearm,
which I'll cover on the next
slide. So what you'll observe
with an AB duction somatic
dysfunction is that you'll
have a proximal ulna that
favors or prefers to
glide medially with distal
forearm AB duction, and an AD
duction somatic dysfunction
is where you'll observe a
proximal ulna that glides
laterally easily when we
adduct the distal forearm.
When evaluating a patient
with an elbow injury
or elbow pain, we're
going to start with
screening. We can screen
by observing the carrying
angle of both arms and
comparing side to side.
We can also assess for
restrictions in active
range of motion of elbow
flexion and extension.
To diagnose adduction and
abduction somatic dysfunctions
of the ulno-humeral joint,
we are going to stand
in front of the patient
who is seated at the table.
We are going to monitor the
proximal ulna so that we
can assess the medial and
lateral glide as we induce
distal forearm AB duction
and AD duction. So the top
image shows how we can
grasp the medial and lateral
aspect of the proximal forearm
with both hands, and then
we going to place the patient's
wrist and hand between
our arm and side to support
it. The bottom image
shows that we can grasp the
proximal forearm with one
hand and then grasp the
patient's wrist or hand with
the other hand. In both
circumstances we are going to
want to have 5 to 45 degrees
of slight elbow flexion.
The motions that we are
going to introduce are
distal forearm AB duction
and distal forearm AD
duction. So in the top
right image, if we move the
distal ulna laterally,
then we are going to assess
or feel for the proximal
ulna moving medially.
In distal forearm AD
duction, we're going to move
the distal ulna medially
and we're going to assess
for the proximal ulna
gliding or moving laterally.
Now let's move on to the
radial head. So I have
the color scheme here to
help keep straight which
landmark is on which
bone. So for the radius,
everything is in green. For
the humerus, everything is
in blue. And for the ulna,
everything is in red.
So the radial humeral
joint is between the
radial head fovea, which
is shown in the top right
image here and the
capitulum of the humerus.
The radial ulnar joint
is between the radial
head and the radial
notch of the ulna and the
radial notch is shown in
that bottom right image.
In each image we see
the annular ligament
and it's shaped like
a tapered cup with the
bottom broken out of
it and you can see that
better on that bottom
right image. This prevents
that distal displacement
of the radius.
Now an example of when the
annular ligament does not
prevent the distal
displacement of the radius is
called nursemaid's elbow.
The mechanism of injury here
is a sudden pull on an
extended and pronated arm.
The most classic or common
example of how this occurs
is shown in the image to
the right where you have
an adult holding on to a
child's arm on each side and
then lifting them into
the air. The child will
experience pain because the
annular ligament becomes
pinched. They'll hold their
arm very close to their body
and have the elbow flexed
and the forearm pronated.
Now to reduce this, it's
called a supination flexion
technique. You're
going to start with the
patient's arm in pronation
and get the elbow flexed
to 90 degrees. With one
hand, you're going to apply
pressure over the subluxed
or dislocated radial
head. And then on the
other hand, you're going
to supinate the forearm
and fully flex the elbow.
This may result in a
click, pop, or clunk. Now
the motions of the
radial head are due
to a combination of
the humeral radial
and proximal radial
ulnar joint motions.
Radial head or radial
ulnar joint somatic
dysfunction is a preference
of either anterior
or posterior glide
of the radial head.
As you can see in
the image to the top
right, when you have
forearm pronation,
the radial head will
glide posteriorly,
and with forearm
supination, you will
have the radial head
glide anteriorly.
And so when we are
describing a posterior radial
head somatic dysfunction,
what we are saying is
that as you pronate
the forearm, the radial
head glides easily posteriorly,
but when you supinate
the forearm, it resists
gliding anteriorly.
Now an anterior radial
head somatic dysfunction
is where with forearm
supination, the radial
head glides anteriorly
easily, but when you pronate
the forearm, it resists
gliding posteriorly.
Now when evaluating
for a forearm injury or
forearm pain, we're going
to start with screening.
We're going to
screen by comparing
side to side the
active range of motion
of forearm supination
and pronation.
Now to diagnose the radial
head we are going to be
standing in front of the
patient who is seated on
the table. Their arms are
going to be in a neutral
position with their elbow
flexed to 90 degrees.
We are then going to
grasp the radial head with
one hand and then with
the other hand we're going
to grasp the distal
forearm or wrist. We're
going to place the forearm
in a neutral position
with the patient's thumb
pointing straight up.
Then we're going to introduce
the motions of pronation
and supination. So as we
introduce pronation, the
distal radius is going to
move anteriorly, while the
proximal radial head is
going to glide posteriorly.
When we introduce
supination, the distal
radius is going to
move posteriorly, while
the proximal radial
head glides anteriorly.
Now, we can also directly
assess the glides
of the radial head
by just pressing or
gliding the radial
head posterior or
anterior without any
pronation or supination.
Now, one caveat is please
note that there can
be a restriction of forearm
pronation or supination
without restriction
of radial head glide.
Now a common mechanism
for a radial head somatic
dysfunction is a fall
on an outstretched hand.
The image to the left
shows a individual falling
forward where the
impact forces the distal
radius anteriorly which
results in the radial
head gliding posteriorly.
The image to the right
shows an individual
falling backward where the
impact forces the distal
radius posteriorly
which results in the
anterior radial head glide.
Now, to understand what
happens when we fall in
an outstretched hand,
we need to understand a
little bit more about the
interosseous membrane.
Now, within the
membrane, there is travel
of blood vessels,
lymph vessels, and
nerves. It also increases
the surface area
for the deep forearm
muscles to attach to.
the fibers of the interosseous
membrane are primarily
oriented from inferior
to medial when we're
describing the direction from
the radius to the ulna so
again inferior and medial
this allows the transfer
of forces from the distal
radiocarpal or wrist joint
up and through the ulna
and then into the humerus.
Now let's move on to the
wrist joint. The wrist
joint doesn't technically
include the ulna. The wrist
joint is the articulation
between the distal
radius and the radial ulnar
disc which you can see
here in the bottom right
image. So you have the
distal radius and then the
radial ulnar articular disc
and it's the articulation
to the scaphoid, lunate,
and triquetrum of the
proximal carpals. And the
radiocarpal joint is a
condyloid synovial joint.
The wrist joint is stabilized
by several ligaments.
On the anterior and
posterior surface, it
is stabilized by the palmar
and dorsal radiocarpal
ligaments. So on the
left image, I mean, we
have the posterior view
of the right hand, and
the dorsal radiocarpal
ligament is shown here.
In the right image,
we have the anterior
view of the right
hand, and we see
the palmar radiocarpal
ligament here.
The ulnar collateral
ligament is seen in the left
image that travels from
the ulnar styloid process
to the triquetrum, and
then the radial collateral
ligament is also seen in
this left image where we go
from the radial styloid
process to the scaphoid.
I'm going to review the
distal radial ulnar joint a
little further. The distal
radial ulnar joint is
stabilized by a complex
referred to as the TFCC. It is
composed of the articular
disc, which is seen here,
the dorsal and ventral
radial ulnar ligaments.
Those are shown here,
the dorsal radial ulnar
ligament, the dorsal
and ventral ulnocarpinal
ligaments, and the floor of
the extensor carpi ulnarius,
or ECU, tendon sheath,
which is shown here.
let's move back to the
radiocarpal joint or wrist joint
and talk about somatic
dysfunction of the wrist which
is not related to gross
motions of the wrist but rather
small gliding motions of
the proximal carpals and
these somatic dysfunctions
are often a combination of
these glides so when we have
wrist extension what the
proximal carpals will do is
glide anteriorly With wrist
flexion, the proximal carpels
will glide posteriorly.
With wrist adduction or
ulnar deviation, the proximal
carpels will glide laterally.
And with abduction or
radial deviation, the
proximal carpels will glide
medially. So the somatic
dysfunctions are named for
that preference. So for
extension somatic dysfunctions,
the proximal carpels
prefer to glide anteriorly
with wrist extension and
resist gliding posteriorly with
wrist flexion. For a
flexion somatic dysfunction,
the proximal carpals
prefer to glide
posteriorly with wrist
flexion and resist
gliding anteriorly
with wrist extension.
For adduction or ulnar
deviation somatic
dysfunction, you'll find
that the proximal carpals
prefer gliding laterally
with wrist ulnar
deviation or adduction and
resist gliding medially
with wrist radial
deviation or abduction.
For an abduction or radial
deviation somatic dysfunction,
the proximal carpals will
prefer to glide medially
with wrist radial
deviation or abduction
but resist gliding
laterally with
wrist ulnar deviation
or adduction.
Evaluating a patient with
wrist injury or wrist
pain, we're going to
start with screening and
the screening is going
to be assessing active
range of motion with the
various wrist motions
and comparing side to
side for any restrictions.
For diagnosing, we're going
to stand in front of the
patient who is seated at
the table. The patient is
going to have their arms
comfortably at their sides,
and their elbows are going
to be flexed to 90 degrees.
And then we're going to
test the following motions,
but I want to make a note
that ulnar and radial
deviation restrictions
may differ if the forearm
is pronated or supinated,
and that's due to the
reciprocal motion of
the ulno-humeral and
radiocarpal joints that
we'll get to in a few slides.
However, restriction
in wrist flexion
and extension
doesn't really differ
with forearm
supinated or pronated.
So we're going to start
at the top right and
the left image in the
top right and we're going
to introduce wrist
extension and we're going to
feel for proximal carpals
gliding anteriorly.
And then the next
image, we're going to
introduce wrist flexion
and we're going to feel
for proximal carpals
gliding posteriorly.
For the next picture in
the middle on the far
right, we're going to
introduce wrist ulnar
deviation or AD duction
and we're going to feel
for the proximal carpals
gliding laterally.
The final picture,
the bottom right,
we're going to
introduce wrist radial
deviation or AB duction
and we're going to
feel for proximal
carpals gliding medially.
Now, we can also just
directly assess the
individual carpal bone
glides in order to diagnose
specific carpal diagnoses,
such as scaphoid,
lunate, or traquetrium
somatic dysfunctions.
But this is the summary of
how you would go about it
for a radiocarpal joint
somatic dysfunction diagnosis.
So let's finish things
off with connecting our
radiocarpal or wrist
somatic dysfunctions to the
omohumeral somatic
dysfunctions we started with.
So there's reciprocal
motion present between the
elbow and wrist due to
the parallelogram effect.
And so when we look
at this image to the
right, and let's
start with letter A,
we're talking
about ulno-humeral
abduction somatic
dysfunction or radiocarpal
adduction somatic dysfunction.
And so if we have an ulno
-humeral abduction somatic
dysfunction, the medial
glide, which is shown by
this black arrow here, is
the preferred motion at
the proximal ulna, which
then likely translates
to a preferred lateral
glide of the distal radius,
and so if you were to find
an ulno-humeral abduction
somatic dysfunction,
you would likely find an
adduction radiocarpal
joint somatic dysfunction.
And the reverse is
true too, where if
you were to find a
radiocarpal adduction
somatic dysfunction,
you would likely find an
ulno-humeral abduction
somatic dysfunction.
Now, to do letter C,
we're going to talk about
ulno-humeral adduction
somatic dysfunction
and radiocarpal abduction
somatic dysfunction.
So at the proximal
ulna, lateral glide
is the preferred motion for an
ulmohumeral adduction
somatic dysfunction,
and this will translate
to a preferred medial
glide of the distal radius.
And so if you were to
find a ulmohumeral adduction
somatic dysfunction,
the likely radiocarpal
joint somatic dysfunction
is an abduction somatic
dysfunction, or vice
versa, where if you find
a radiocarpal abduction
somatic dysfunction you'll
likely find a omohumeral
adduction somatic dysfunction
and here is a list
of the references for
the lecture and handout
and here is the lecture
feedback link please
provide any feedback
on how i can improve
upon this lecture or the
lab handout and i look
forward to working with
everyone in the lab